immortals phoenix rising has somehow
become synonymous with the legend of
zelda breath of the wild
they're two really different games but
with some very clear similarities that
are just hard to
pull apart from one another so let's get
down to the bottom of this
and look at both of them and see how
much alike they are and what one offers
something that's different than the
other
so who's better to join me than our very
own breath of the wild expert
max also known as rinharasaki got about
50 hours on immortals and
on uh breath of the wild so you might
have a thing or two to say
just just a couple things just a couple
things
[Music]
so to jump into this whole thing we're
gonna break it down into three major
sections we're going to talk about
exploration then we're going to talk
about combat
and then puzzle so to kick this off
exploration
now exploration is one of the most
defining characteristics of breath of
the wild and it's also a
big thing to do in immortals phoenix
rising but again
both games handle them in totally
different ways they do have big
expansive massive worlds with beautiful
vistas
but one is a little bit more streamlined
when the other one is all about
curiosity max how do you view all that
yeah the two games on surface level
obviously seem really familiar you know
they both got the open world aspect
it even goes a little more granular than
that i mean they both got like a
quadrant based system around
a final boss those kind of like surface
level comparisons are pretty obvious but
they do have quite a few differences
immortals even does improve on breath of
the wild in some respect
water areas specifically where breath of
the wild where you can't really do
anything immortals does give you the
option to
you know maneuver more by jumping or
diving underneath the water in those
respects it does give you
some a little bit more of an edge but
it's obvious where they took the
inspirations from you know there's
mounts and
horses and there's running and gliding
and
it's pretty similar now yeah yeah but
there's but there's only one of them
has has shield surfing yeah that's true
you can't shield surf and immortal so
it's basically unplayable exactly i mean
but the thing is
the worlds do have that kind of similar
feeling openness
quality that that have things in the
distance that are compelling to push the
player forward it's just
in the case of immortals it's telling
you where to go you have a thing at the
top of your screen
that's telling you where your next
objective is just having that feature
there kind of
sways the player away from having any
freedom to look and explore
where breath of the wild just takes all
that away from you the way you explore
the game is by seeing things in the
distance marking things on the map and
seeing a tower of light in the sky but
in mortals
it's more traditional and gamey in that
sense but in that case
makes the experience more streamlined
which some players
may want different people will have
different reactions to how you approach
traversal in this game
it's definitely not traditional breath
of the wild it's pretty traditional
ubisoft in the sense that
it just kind of leads you to the
waypoint to the next waypoint in the
next waypoint
in breath of the wild you had the kind
of natural discovery of just looking
around and seeing
some big glowing object in the distance
and you're just
curious so you you know made a marker to
go to it and then you just kind of went
to it
uh just out of wanting to go immortal
phoenix rising
does have that in a sense but it really
robs that with
the farsight mechanic where you can
literally just ping
anything and know what it is through
walls and just
mark everything on your map so it's just
littered with a whole bunch of waypoints
of what you need to do
which you know some people like that
mechanic but i i feel like breath of the
wild really nailed that in the sense
that you really want to do it because
you want to do it not because the game
is telling you this is where you need to
go
there's one thing though um that i do
think is
extremely similar and that is the
difference in towers and then i forget
what they're called immortals when you
go up to the top of the
statues and you see the entire thing and
it reveals the area on the map those two
things are basically
exactly the same yeah uh it's that's
synonymous of ubisoft i guess you could
say i mean the quote unquote ubisoft
towers
people have been coining that breath of
wild might have taken that from ubisoft
so it might have been almost a trade in
that respect
it's not a bad thing it's it's pretty
pretty normal gameplay routine at this
point and i i do enjoy it because then
you get to obviously see where
everything is in the world and then you
get
kind of lean your exploration from there
next up we're going to talk about
combat and thankfully not only is max a
breath of the wild specialist he's a
combat specialist this dude
is very good at video games he pretty
much lifts all of us up
thing is with combat in this game is
again black exploration
there is some really big differences but
then there's also some key
similarities and you being the combat
specialist that you are tell me a bit
about that tell me about the key things
you think
are different between these two games so
this is where immortals
actually does thrive pretty well it does
have a completely different
layout to breath of the wild's combat i
mean there are some similarities here
and there you know perry's and
flurry rushes quote unquote but the
overall combat is actually
really really different and when people
play and
you know get through the combat as
they're growing into the game they're
probably have their own two cents on how
it feels to them but
to me it kind of had two layers it had
one small layer of like anime fighters
where it had
you know the jump double jump and jump
air dash mechanic
so you can kind of use that to your
advantage to dodge and approach enemies
and it also has the kind of more obvious
devil may cry approach where you can
like pull yourself to enemies pull to
them
do special abilities and kind of make
these crazy combos that
really is pretty flashy it is really
cool honestly i think the only two key
like similarities in combat between
breath of the wild and immortals
is the flurry rush and the perry
otherwise
i would say immortals has a lot more
going on for it i mean in terms like you
have
the additional acts for like heavy hits
and stuff like that as well as your
sword and also we cannot not talk about
the fact
that weapons don't break in immortals
that is one of the key things in the
combat
of breath of the wild you just have
these set weapons and you got them
that's all you got you don't have to
deal with it so for people out there who
complained
or don't like the weapon system breath
of wild this is something that immortals
might do better
for you and that's one of the things
that i think is so interesting about
how this game has become i understand
how this game has become so closely
compared to it because there's such
obvious things there but i feel like
once you really get hands-on with
immortals and you actually experience
its combat in certain mechanics
it starts to feel like a drastically
different game personally that i think
is made
for a different audience of gamer not
saying that the same person can't enjoy
both these games
but i i kind of feel like immortals is
is
dare i say broader it's for a broader
audience i would argue and i think the
combat itself and the fact that there
isn't
you know destructible weapons you just
have the same set of weapons the entire
time is really telling
as you know a part of immortals battle
system identity
also i mean i'm part of like the one
percent of breath of the wild players
who are like
really mega deep into the game so in
that respect
there is definitely more depth in breath
of the wild than
in immortal phoenix rising i mean there
might be some tech later on that might
be found in immortal phoenix rising but
in the end i say breath of the wild
on the surface for regular players is
not as in-depth
than immortals phoenix rising it's funny
because like as we were talking about
this i was like yeah breath of the
wild's
combat system isn't that i'm not saying
it's not in depth but it definitely you
know on surface level
you have a weapon and you hit it you
have a shield and you dodge and there's
stuff like that but when you consider
the different weapon types and the
different kinds of weapons and the
different durability between those
weapons and how you can change and
interact with those weapons
definitely starts to in a very good way
blow into
craziness when when you have the skills
that you do max to be able to do that
but in a sense i think you know on a
surface level when you're approaching
something like immortals it feels like
it's more in depth there are combo
systems which breath of the wild doesn't
have
but i think you bring up an excellent
point that to some degree
breath of wild is has a lot more depth
in that sense just maybe not in the way
a traditional gamer might be familiar
with it
so we've touched on exploration which i
personally think wall is very similar
there are some key differences that
push the players in two very different
ways and i kind of think the same way
with combat
puzzles on the other hand i think is the
thing
that makes immortals
look like a breath of the wild clone at
times
as i was playing the game i was like
this doesn't feel that much like breath
of wild like you can see inspirations
like you could see inspirations from any
other game
once you get into those what are they
even called immortals they're not
shrines
they're called bolts they're called
vaults they're called shrines they're
basically i i can't i don't know how to
get around this this is this to me is
the most
clear inspiration from breath of the
wild
is the vault the vault feels so much
like shrines it's almost a little goofy
to me
um what are your feelings on that the
layout is pretty much
one-to-one the system of going to a
place going into like a separate world
to do this puzzle and then getting a
single
power off of it to grow yourself is
pretty similar but the puzzles are
actually
pretty tough in some situations and what
i do enjoy about mortals phoenix
rising's puzzles is that the
powers can come into play to sort of
cheese some situations and
that's kind of important in these kind
of open world games is to
give you some powers to use to kind of
bend
the laws of the world to make you feel
like a genius breath of the wild did
that
way better in my opinion because you
know you can do things like
lift a heavy weapon with magnesis to
give yourself shade from the desert so
you don't
you don't overheat or you can you know
half cut a tree and then stasis that and
give yourself cover to make a campfire
in the middle of rain
uh you can hit yourself with like a choo
choo jelly on
death mountain and like you know give
yourself 30 seconds of invulnerability
from fire because you're wet
like those kind of rules of the world is
what makes breath of the wild strong
immortals has a tiny bit of that and no
other game has really come close to
breath of the wild's ingenuity in that
factor
and immortals does have those godly
powers which you can sort of use those
physics in those
powers to kind of cheese some of the
portions of the puzzles and you could
use some of the hammers to like hit the
balls where you're not supposed to go
and like make them bounce or use the
spears to break objects where you're not
supposed to and then use those to
lift it into places that you couldn't
before so the puzzles
can be tough but with those godly powers
that you do accrue then you can start
using
some pretty cool mechanics yeah i think
i think
unfortunately for me i've been able to
take myself out of
my romantic affair with breath of the
wild while playing immortals i'm able to
play it and see that they are two very
very different games
that do different things for a different
player
but for me it's whenever i'm in those
vaults that's
kind of when i start to think even if
the puzzles are challenging in some
places
i that i can't disassociate it with some
of the most brilliant challenging
puzzles i had to deal with in breath of
the wild
and i don't know if maybe just it's i
haven't spent enough time with immortals
in comparison to you but i've been left
uninspired by a lot of them
there was also one particular case in
the game earlier in the game when um
there's a puzzle
outside and you have to collect these
blue orbs but they show you where the
orbs are
like you just like it just it doesn't
leave any imagination
or exploration to the player to be able
to find it on their own that took me out
of it i was like that was one of the
first moments where i was like i think
i'd rather be doing this in front of the
wild
it definitely feels more like tasks yes
phoenix rising compared to
like a natural want to yes
solve the puzzle in breath of the wild i
i think like out of all the three things
we've looked at i think
puzzles for me are kind of the main
point where
it's hard for me to take myself out of
it it's hard for me to
not think that one game not only did it
better
but it's obvious where ideas were taken
that's that's that's the one category of
these three where it stumbles
the most for me so here we are we've
gone over three major defining factors
of these two
games and honestly the thing that have
come to the conclusion is is that i feel
like breath of the wild has just kind of
just made his own genre at this point
and now we're starting to get games that
are adapting
these very key characteristics that kind
of make
this new breath of the wild genre we've
been calling certain games
souls born or souls game and i think
this this is kind of the equivalent here
we have the the the botw
genre now and i think immortals phoenix
rising and gentian impact
are two games that are really telling of
that but at the end of the day
i do still think immortals is a much
different experience than breath of wild
and
in some regards kind of unfair to
compare but then there's certain regards
like vaults
and shrines that are a little bit more
obvious ultimately
i think they're for two different
audiences maybe one for more streamline
experience but that's just me max what
do you think yeah
i think that immortals definitely does a
different audience than breath of the
wild
i think both are strong in certain
aspects and you know immortals has some
things over breath of the wild you know
better swimming mechanics and stuff like
that but
i think breath of the wild is such an
anchor
in that type of
gaming the open world type of game that
it's hard to really
live up to it and i don't think
immortals really tried to do that i
don't think they tried to
exactly match one for one obviously but
it's always hard to play a game that's
like breath of the wild and not compare
it to it it's just
you can't get away from it i think we're
gonna see a few more games try to do
this and we'll eventually see it kind of
either till breath of wild 2 comes out
or another game that kind of takes the
formula and changes it but
there we have it the verses or at least
the differences in conversations for
both
legend zelda breath of the wild and
immortals phoenix praising so for all
the stuff that we're covering including
max's
sweet combat videos and breakdowns and
comparisons
to both these games and other games and
all that jazz
stay here at gamespot again i'm kurt
davina this is max
also known as brainarasaki that guy
alright thanks guys thanks for joining
us hope this was helpful
see you later
[Music]
you